We are going to san francisco
要出
♪ 星星下班上班开会 ♪
♪ 王个美丽 ♪
♪ 下班约会 ♪
♪ 回想我们天生一对 ♪
♪ Oh oh oh yeah ♪
♪ 要迷恋我的香水 ♪
眼泪先会抓住你位
♪ 这种女神要去哪追 ♪
♪ 快说你爱不爱我 ♪
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪
♪ 浪漫情话不嫌多 ♪
♪ My baby b ♪
我有稍微提前了几天
就是想说先来调个时差
能够有一个最好的状态
我也是很怕以时间上来看的话
就是演出的时间只是时差可能是最严重的时候
所以我有比大家早了几天吧
然后顺便来感受一下这个西岸
旧金山这两座城市
♪ Boy ♪
♪ 我会天天付出我的爱 ♪
♪ Baby boy ♪
♪ Hug me ♪
♪ Oh how can i smiso b ♪
♪ 只要你为我爽快快 ♪
♪ Oh my baby boy ♪
因为之前有些是比较重
然后下肢比较轻
所以你们就好像比较人是像你礼貌
那你上学
这是我小学才会有个很整齐
明天要出去就会明文在家替你改变
♪ 让世界多么完美 ♪
我要come to one CD v
oh oh可爱
情话不嫌多
my baby b巴掌
其实有点紧张
为什么呢
因为来到了美国做了一个特别的版本
在舞台上其实是跟平常不太一样
我们也为这个新的舞台做了新的排练
本来应该是得心应手
但是因为我们做了一个特别限定版
但是我相信大家都可以
他新来到了帝国
耶啊开心还是路
有了大家的一个陪伴
一起克服了很多困难
一起跨越了很多挑战
今天美国奥克兰
Let's go
Cindy
Super lady
We are ready
我和娜上台了
拜奥克兰乌萨乌萨放轻松快乐摇摆
张开双手迎接蓝蓝大海
不散不散
把烦恼统统抛开
♪ Say yeah ♪
say耶
菩萨菩萨
你的把戏差一点改变了我所有信念
♪ 看过的首听的歌 ♪
♪ 早餐咖啡的口味 ♪
我去逛了MOA美术馆
看了海
看了胖胖的海报
然后也做了摩天轮这些画面
这些感觉这些一瞬间都是我今天站在这里
把自己交给你们的养分
能够把演唱会带来到美国
带来到奥克兰
跟大家做近距离见面
这个真的是个很难得的机会
所以啊当然要很谢谢你们
尤其尤其是最谢谢你们
♪ 都有你善意的谎言让我心碎 ♪
♪ 直到最后一片才看见从未到过的地方 ♪
♪ 原来是你欣赏 ♪
天纽约纽约的第一天
从西岸到东岸还是有三个小时的时差
我们现在要摇摇得跟自由女神相望一下
这个方向的空气
刘海上一次来到纽约
郎不郎当
20年前好可怕啊
时间过得好快
突然期待某上次来的时候
我有点忘记我们跟自由女神相望
可能有吧有吧
嗯可他就是没有跟他近距离的接触嘛
所以这次也回味一下20年前的感觉
现在没想到时隔20年一样
在纽约的madison square garden开演唱会咯
呀shy shining my way
♪ Shining my day ♪
♪ My shining ♪
♪ Shining my way ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Ring ♪
♪ 要 ♪
来到一个真的没有唱过的
你真的很懂点
shining王心凌
你比加州阳光还帅呢
真的吗
暖暖的空气亲吻刘海
♪ 尽管温柔的山脉 ♪
♪ 我都裙摆 ♪
Shiny shy
♪ Shining my way ♪
♪ Shining me ♪
♪ Shining ♪
♪ Shining whole day ♪
给你